ein entwickler drei spiele einmal müssen
sie springen einmal müssen sie fallen
einmal müssen sie kämpfen heute müssen
sie springt man allerdings nicht
verstanden haben ich habe hier meinen
ipad und es gibt drei spiele namens
major make them for mac dem feld von dem
entwicklerstudio ketchup heißen die
glaube ich und ich habe mir gedacht ich
spiele alle drei in unterschiedlichen
videos bearbeitet das ganz cool wie ich
das mit dem edding steve chang macht
habe ich habe meine brille wieder auf
und ich würde sagen wir dann mit dem
ersten spiel wird das natürlich der
super erklären autoplay to make the
first major zusätzlich ist das prinzip
immer so ich muss einmal oben drücken
dann springt die person oben und unten
drücken dann passiert etwas unten und
das ist bei allen spielen so ihr seht
schon ich habe das spiel sehr gut bisher
verstanden mal heiße bei null und wir
haben da garantiert mal angepackt
ich glaube ich muss da nicht zu sagen
ich mache jetzt so und österreich bis 6
nein ich hatte das die ganze zu und hab
dann nur unten gedrückt und blauen klub
und ich habe ich keine ahnung wie lange
diese videos immer lange diese videos
immer werden weil ich halte nicht weiß
wie lange ich immer durchhalte bei so
einem ding
er war doch quasi doch einfach drüber
laufen ich will das ist 1000 mal dass
diese werbung sehe und ich würde nie was
ist das für ein spiel den ganzen anderen
spielen war es ja immer so da mein ipad
aber ich gab ihm eine tastatur
produktion statt einander taktik ich
halte das ipad jetzt mal anders und
schon deswegen mal was passiert jetzt
fakt 18 12 fakt bleibt ja das ist aber
auch so schwer das ganze zu koordinieren
alter mann denkt erst mal bestimmt so
beim zuschauen so jo geht wohl fühlt man
aber jetzt gerade bin ich auch ich habe
hier schon wieder auch sehr cool ich
habe gerade einfach mal aus versehen auf
die leertaste gehauen und
dementsprechend wurde meine aufnahme
dann unterbrochen aber gut sein
die stören wir haben jetzt hier einfach
mal eben kurzen highscore aus kommen
seine c spitze
ich will dieses spiel nicht spielen ich
will auch keine web was ist das was ist
also ob ins spiel was das wir werden das
dann nicht mal name bei steht ja wieder
meine babo dann basteln wir jetzt mal
eben hier seinen highscore hin ich meine
das ist ja eine sache die wir da ganz
locker eben machen kölner denken jetzt
die meisten wieder acht com das sagt er
doch immer dass dein heiß gemacht ich
springe ich halt sonst in den videos nie
an ich trinke ich nur an wenn nicht dann
alle wollen das neue video sag ich jetzt
natürlich immer so als ich meine ich sag
jetzt vorher schon ich will 9
ja ich möchte auch keine neuen high
score deswegen gestorben
ich bin vielleicht muss man werbung für
apple machen dann ich glaube der oberen
über kopfschmerzen und knieschmerzen
alles möglich
guckt euch das mal an
der war da nicht mal drauf sein fuß noch
in der luft und das spiel das hasst mich
dass das spiel bricht schon ab was fällt
dem einen guck mal ich hab für punkte im
gewicht von der sonne kontrakte macht
doch mal flugmodus rein damit du keine
werbung hast ja aber ich nehme das mit
einer app auf für die ich wlan brauche
deswegen brauche ich da internet und
kein flug modus
diese apps hol dir denkst wie so wurden
die gemacht da regt man sich nur bei auf
anstatt dass diese blöcke auch mal
irgendwie zeitgleich kommen dass man da
zeitgleich drücken kann so wie jetzt
gerade jetzt läuft jetzt läuft heftig 20
20 00 wer auch so einen doppeljob aber
das dann auch so doppelt große gebäude
kommen
luca dass das wäre nicht cool ein doppel
große gebäude kommen würden dann würde
ich mich noch mehr aufrichten
und immer wenn ich sage dass ein
einheitsball mache dann mache ich das
auch
das ist ein schritt weg super da mach
ich habe mache ich halt eben nur ein
reiskorn hatte angekündigt
23 hier lokale denkt immer dass ich mal
so viele züge aufnehmen will sich dann
jemand neuen highscore habe aber nie das
war halt wirklich gerade das andere das
direkter was habe ich eigentlich wieder
kombi die brille macht dich total
dommusik zwei elegante haus aber den
gehirnzellen dadurch bewusst viele
geschrieben aber ich glaube hier einfach
alter ich kann nicht dumm sein ich hab
mir heiß kaufen
ich hab mal high score von 25
also ist das ganze spiel eigentlich
rassistisch gegenüber weißen die ganze
strichmännchen sind die immer in schwarz
in diesen spielen gar nicht gesagt dass
ich ein heiß gemacht hab ich sag das
jetzt mal eben dass ich an mache dann
wird das ein heftiges dicker 30 was los
ich habe mir vor eigentlich gesagt wenn
ich über 20 kommen heute direkt mit dem
video so rein innerlich aber jetzt schon
30 mal was denn los mit mir waren
erfolgreicher ich wohne in hamburg auch
relativ zentral und hier fährt
direktionen bahn immer vorher so eine
straßenbahn und hörte das eigentlich
wenn jetzt mal ein paar
kurz nicht angemacht deswegen ich glaube
das wäre schon lauter scooter sich das
hat mit den rausch denkt
auch fürs ipad shapes of grey was ist
herzog break obwohl viele räume ich
bleib jetzt so damit mich die sonne hier
nicht weiter nervt tschuldigung zeit die
mich da nicht besser gehen könnte
aber das ist natürlich er ist einfach
ein blog drin wahrscheinlich nicht oder
wird stellte einfach im block aber
freundlich kündige an highscore okay gut
kann highscore ich bin direkt auch noch
gestorben aber hey wenn es zehn stunden
geschlafen doch shades of prey der blaue
ist mir irgendwie mal viel sympathischer
achte irgendwie immer nur auf dem blauen
und bei dem unteren sich immer nur diese
ging
tschuldigung roter du musst nicht gleich
in block reinlaufen nur weil ich gedacht
hatte ich mit denen ich sympathisiere
können es natürlich ganz locker klären
oder wir machen jetzt einfach mal eben
kurz neuen ice konnte das ist natürlich
dann die art egal die blöcke kommen wird
richtig gut zum drüberziehen 1 3 und
sonstige fusseln weil ich meinen spinnen
dingen hier abgelegt habe habe ich aber
gerade etwas kaputt gemacht und ich gebe
uns noch ein paar versuche diese videos
keine ahnung von solchen spielen können
die videos der uni lang werden weil sie
ja noch eine sache gibt die man machen
kann rein theoretisch deswegen werde ich
jetzt einfach mich noch mal so ein
bisschen daran probieren und versuchen
einen highscore zu knacken in diesem
land und ihr wisst freunde immer wenn
ich sage mutv horrorfilme filme wie
jetzt neu die kosten
nein ich will gewinnen spiel spielen
allerdings verstehen ich mache immer
irgendwas kaputt hier alle schon wieder
als am heidener produktplatzierung durch
die ganze werbung die du landest
verdammt mein iphone hoeneß ist sogar
rot und letztes mal zimmer richtig gut
geklappt als man mich nicht gesehen hat
mag ich hab ja auch sehen die steuerung
falsch gemacht ich habe aus versehen
einen anderen daumen oben also das war
nicht meine erfolgs taktik von vorhin
die ich jetzt gerade an wände
aber es läuft trotzdem gerade ganz gut
ich sollte nie wieder sagen das ist nein
ich hab schon wieder die falsche taktik
ich vollidiot jetzt macht es richtig
fick dich booty wieso leute ich bring
diesen run jetzt eben noch zu ende und
sag euch dann welchen score ich dann am
ende erreicht hat bzw zeigt euch das in
diesem end menü das läuft richtig gut
das konnten richtig hohe high score
werden man das könnte richtig hohe high
score werden
dort wird ein richtig guter highscore
leute ihr seht eingeblendet das ist mein
letzter highscore 4100 habe ich dann
geschafft da war es da langsamer zu ende
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen ausgehungert
ich muss als auch endlich mal was essen
weil ich das spiele zahlt drei tage am
stück gespielt hab ich habe meinen magen
knurrt doch schon die ganze zeit also
ich würd sagen ich hab auch noch fünf
prozent ab
das ist richtig gut das war es mit der
ersten episode von make them oder so es
gibt ja nur drei weil die nur drei
spiele gemacht haben dass man merkt wenn
ihr die nächste episode wollt also
märkten voll da müssen wir runter
springen und nur sachen und tatsächlich
was das ist dass wir das zusammen
herausfinden anlass eine positive
wertung kommen da rennt man erst mal
wieder das gute